welcome to cloud onair
live webinars from google cloud we host
these webinars
every tuesday my name is jeremy sussman
i'm a product manager on google docs and
today
i'll be talking to you about tips and
tricks to boost productivity on google
docs
you can ask questions anytime on the
platform we have googlers standing by
to answer them this talk is a quick
overview of google docs
if you want to learn more please visit
the g suite learning center
we'll give you a link at the end of the
talk ok
let's get started
sorry
having trouble technical troubles
okay sorry about that
one of the most common things you do at
work is to write documents
you might write a proposal a technical
specification document
a legal contract or even use a document
to capture meeting notes
in this talk we're going to walk through
the typical lifecycle of a document
it often goes something like this you
kick off the document by copying an
existing document and removing the
information
you then add in other information that
you have on hand
you then share the document with your
teammates and stakeholders some of whom
may be external to your company
to build up the content once you've
gotten all the information you need in
the document
you go through it all again and add that
extra level of polish
and finally you send your document out
to its intended audience
in this presentation i'm going to
highlight how google docs saves you time
during each of these four steps okay
let's talk about starting a new document
as i said often when starting a new
document
people will make a copy of an existing
document
remove all the old content and then
start adding new content
although this is a very common practice
it is not the most efficient
a better way to do this is by using
templates
a template is basically a common outline
of a document
it removes the time spent copying and
cleaning up old files
in the workplace giving you more time
for the important creative work
with the custom template feature you can
create a template from any file
and then submit it to the template
gallery for your co-workers to adapt and
use as needed
g suite for business and education
customers can restrict who can submit
new templates
or require templates to be approved by
an administrator before they appear in
the gallery
finding templates across a big
organization can be time consuming and
often impossible
with the template gallery in google docs
organizations can distribute their
up-to-date templates
and group them by team a template that
is custom to your team
allows you to focus less on formatting
and more on driving impact and achieving
success
we talked about starting off from a
template and customizing it to produce
your end result
but what if you need to produce 10 very
similar documents
in certain job functions like sales
there's a common workflow where you send
similar documents to many customers
this is a timing consuming process for
each customer
you make a copy of the template and then
edit the name of the customer and the
data about the customer
you have to do that one customer at a
time but with google docs it will soon
be possible to automate this process
using our application programming
interface or api
these apis are built for reading and
writing presentations
spreadsheets and documents from your
application
the rest api for docs is currently in
developer preview
rest apis work really well if you have
an on-premise or legacy data store you
need to work with
it's a nice way to integrate with a
cloud-based product like g suite
even if you aren't fully on the cloud
just yet we built this api
because of a wide ranging need to
support several core use cases
specifically bulk document creation
content management
and workflow management for example you
could create a program that runs on your
existing infrastructure
reads from an on-premise system and
pushes data out into a docs template
this could automate the sales scenario i
just mentioned for example
or you could add an export to docs
button on an internal site
this could push the data on the page to
a document where you can get the benefit
of our collaborative editing
capabilities now you have docs editors
right where you need them
no matter what tool you're using as i
mentioned
the rest api for docs is currently in
developer preview
you can sign up for early access at
developers.google.com
docs so
templates give you a head start with the
formatting the layout but is there a way
to get a head start on the content in
your document
often you have a lot of existing work
information other docs
slides or spreadsheets that form the
basis of your new document
we want to help you easily find that
information
docs explore uses artificial
intelligence
to suggest relevant files for you it
does this based on your previous drive
activity
and information in your documents this
allows you to find the most up-to-date
information
and create new material quickly
you can also search manually for files
emails
or even the web for more content just
click the explore icon
at the bottom right of your screen to
benefit from this great feature
often the information in a document
especially charts and tables
comes from a spreadsheet if the
information in the original chart or
table changes it can be difficult to
remember
to update copies of those charts or
tables and other documents
and it can be tedious and time consuming
when you do
to save you valuable time you could
choose to link
charts and tables that come from
spreadsheets if you do that
we will remind you that the data has
changed and we make it possible to
update your chart with a single click
without ever needing to leave your
document or presentation
this way you maintain a single source of
truth and update content in new
documents with a click of a button
this can be great to keep the data in
important documents ever green
similarly it is often useful to embed a
slide in a document
like charts or tables slides can be
linked ensuring that they too remain up
to date
there's another document starting aid
that's coming soon to google docs
the g suite quick access side panel that
appears in gmail today
will soon be available in google docs so
how is this useful for starting a doc
well for example if you know there's a
document you'll need to write
you could outline it in google keep
using lightweight notes while you're on
the go
then when you sit down to write the
actual document you can use the g suite
side panel
to get started by just dragging and
dropping your notes from keep
into the document with the g suite side
panel
you can use the full power of the g
suite tools
without having to navigate navigate a
lot of open windows
finally we've built an even cooler way
to get a head start on a specific type
of document
meeting nodes research has demonstrated
that agendas are widely beneficial for
creating efficient high quality meetings
tracking agendas and capturing action
items make meetings more productive and
effective
here's a sneak peek at a new feature of
google docs quick meeting notes
quick meeting notes integrate with
google calendar to help attendees
quickly set up meeting note documents
it makes tracking agendas notes and
action items easy
with a simple template to keep meetings
more productive
we'll talk more about action items in a
few minutes
okay so in step one you save time by
creating from starting from a template
and quickly adding information from
other sources like charts
date tables and slides now that you have
a good starting point
you're ready to bring your teammates in
to collaborate on the document
this is where google docs really shines
let's see how this is done
with all google documents being in the
cloud you don't send your collaborators
a copy
at no point do you need to label a
document as version 1
send it out to others and then wait for
the next version to be emailed back to
you
while you sit there unproductively
wondering what your colleagues are doing
what you see on this screen is how
collaboration works in google docs
multiple people are making multiple
changes all in real time
even if your colleagues work in
different time zones and in different
parts of the world
you all work on the same document never
again will you have to deal with this
version roulette because everyone is
working on the exact
same file people nowadays often work on
the go while commuting to the office or
traveling on a business trip
the real-time collaboration features are
all available on our apps
on ios and on android
sometimes it can take dozens of edits to
make a document just right
especially a legal agreement project
proposal or research paper
to reduce the messiness of it all
collaborators can suggest
changes this feature stores their
changes for review instead of changing
the content directly
you can then look through the
suggestions and approve or reject each
one as you see fit
and as with collaboration suggested
changes are part of our mobile apps
with google docs you can also name
versions of a document
preview clean versions and bulk accept
or reject all changes
named versions of a document allow you
to assign custom names
to specific versions of your document
this is a great way to keep a historical
record of your team's progress
it's also helpful for communicating when
a document is actually final
previewing clean versions of a document
allows you to see what your doc would
look like
without the comments or suggested edits
finally bulk acceptance or rejection of
all edit suggestions
means you or your teammates don't have
to review every single punctuation mark
or formatting update
with one click you can bring the
document to the version that you want
the collective power of a team can help
to get things done quickly
but effective teams generate lots of
to-do's and action items
which can be hard to track google docs
makes collaboration easier
easier with comments and action items
and can even suggest
action items automatically comments in
google docs allow your team members to
leave suggestions or notes on what to
edit or add
other editors working on the document
can see and respond to comments
this is the magic of google docs
collaboration come to life
action items in google docs allow you to
assign tasks to others
you can assign an action item manually
to someone by mentioning their name in a
comment
and checking the action item box the
assignee will get an email
notification to see the action item and
it will they will see them clearly
highlighted with a blue bar when they
open the file
and with suggested action items google
docs identifies potential to do's
and smartly suggests turning them into
actual assigned two dues for easy
tracking
so on desktop for example if you type
phrases like
when to follow up on the keynote script
or li to schedule a weekly check-in
docs will intelligently suggest an
action item to assign to the right
person
thanks to natural language processing
sometimes when you are collaborating
sometimes when you are collaborating
with an external agency
they don't use google docs whether
you're negotiating a contract with a
client
or coordinating a sales agreement with a
supplier chances are you might have to
deal with multiple file formats
in google drive you can comment on those
files the way you're used to in google
docs
no need to open up other tools to get
the collaborative benefit of google docs
in the drive preview pane comment assign
tasks or mention co-workers on any file
and the people you work with can reply
back this is true even if they're not
using g suite
let's say your co-worker opens a file on
her windows laptop
using microsoft word she'll see your
comment in the file and can reply right
from there
the ability to comment in drive preview
mode is just one example of the
interoperability
between g suite and microsoft office
products
for some documents in addition to
collaborators you might also have
stakeholders or approvers
you may need to get your proposal or
contract approved by stakeholders in
various functions
like legal or pr without g suite
you'd probably download the document as
pdf and then use a product tracking tool
to collect formal approvals and
sign-offs
okay sure that works but if any of the
approvers
asks for a change in the contract or
presentation you need to make that
change
produce a new pdf somehow differentiate
that version from the first one
and then resend it for approval and as i
said earlier
version roulette is a hassle with g
suite this approval workflow is a whole
lot more streamlined
we recently announced drive's upcoming
centric workflows feature
which will allow users to get formal
approvals on federal approvals on their
files
with this feature you submit a file for
approval from specific co-workers
and upon doing so the file gets locked
and shared and the approvers get
notified
after the document is approved the file
stays locked
and anybody looking at the file will be
able to tell that the file has been
approved
this lightweight workflow tool can
powerfully streamline company processes
and will soon be available in an early
adopters program
for this type of approval or sign-off
process when you have many stakeholder
stakeholders
it's helpful to be able to track their
progress
google docs offers the ability to audit
collaborator activity
the activity dashboard allows you to see
which collaborators have viewed your
document
and when you can understand which of
your teammates have seen your latest
revision
and who needs to be notified that they
need to stay in the loop
google docs gives you the power to track
the progress on a project
with lots of moving parts
okay we've talked about starting your
document and collecting information with
others
and we talked about collaborating around
that document what does google do
to help you help you save time with the
fine-grained
copy and polish
one feature in google docs that helps
you get to that level of polish
is our default text styles feature
google docs allows you to set up custom
title and heading styles
with custom styles you get formatting
that matches your company's brand
or your own personal style this makes it
easy for you to keep that level of
polish you want
without expanding a lot of extra energy
fonts matter for polish too there are
some that are good for documents that
are read on a personal screen
while others are good for the big screen
you can choose from hundreds of fonts
provided by google slides we recently
expanded the font catalog to support 62
languages
including non-latin scripts like
cyrillic and divinagari
once you find fonts you like you can add
them to your my fonts list
once they're in this list they will be
available for quick access
in the font drop-down menu on all of
your docs files
we've found in our user research there
are three top cases
where people worry the most about the
quality of their writing
in high-stakes internal collaboration
communications
when you're drafting communications that
drive key business decisions
in external collaboration when you're
drafting a document or proposal
with the intention of sharing this
outside of your company and
when you're collaborating as a
non-native speaker when you're not the
native speaker of the official language
of your company or industry
in all these cases it's critical to
ensure that your writing is correct
we are introducing grammar suggestions
in google docs
along with a revamped interface for your
spelling and grammar review
these new features build on the existing
spell check functionality
to also highlight possible grammar
errors in your text and help you correct
them
this will help you spend less time
checking and proofreading your work
and make your writing easier to
understand
google docs uses machine learning
technology to recognize and help correct
potential grammar
grammar errors in real time when docs
detects a
possible grammar correction it will
underline it in blue to indicate you
might want to check it
you can then right click to see a
suggested correction or dismiss
the alert possible grammar errors will
also show up
when you run a spelling and grammar
check through the tools menu
these features will initially launch as
an early adopter program
another place to find polishing help is
in the add-on store
here you can find rich integrations to
help you build more powerful documents
for example you can add diagrams you
created in programs outside of g suite
like in lucidchart or you can more
easily generate bibliographies and
citations
using the easybib add-on explore the
add-on store for a variety of helpful
tools
okay so we've created the document we've
worked with our collaborators
we've gotten the approvals needed
everything's polished and buttoned up
and now we're ready to send out our work
how does google docs help you in this
phase of
creating a document
when it comes to documents in the
enterprise world security matters
when there's extra sensitive information
in a document you want to be
conservative
about what the recipients can do with
the file for example
you may give some stakeholders view-only
access
this prevents them from changing their
own access level and allowing other new
people to be able to access the file
you can also prevent downloading or
making a copy of the document
this type of protection is not possible
in a world where you attach files in an
email
for the others to download and forward
at their will
to keep your organization's information
extra safe in these situations
you can also set an expiration date for
specific user actions
by user access to files in google docs
for instance
imagine your business hires an outside
contractor for a project lasting three
months to complete that job the
contractor needs to view a document
containing confidential information
about your company you share the
document containing this information
with the contractor
give them view access only and c set
that access to expire when their
contract
does in three months now if the
contractor attempts to open the document
after the expiration date has passed
they'll be denied access
google docs strives to give you full
control over how your files are shared
and this is all done with a few clicks
and a self-explanatory user interface
with google docs all the phases of
creating a document okay
sorry google docs also gives you a
choice
on how you want to share your document
while the easiest and most common way
is to share the file natively with the
right access controls as i just
mentioned
you might want you might want to share
it in a different format
you can see here the various formats
into which you can export your final
product
without losing any formatting
with google docs all the phases of
creating a document getting started
collaborating polishing and sharing are
easier and more efficient
in this talk we've taken you through a
bunch of great google docs features
custom templates in the template gallery
developer apis to generate documents
explore
and suggested data linked charts tables
and slides that remain up to date
the quick access side panel quick
meeting notes
collaboration with comments and action
items manual or automatically suggested
suggested changes in the ability to bulk
accept or reject them
named versions and clean previews
approvals and sign-offs in google docs
or on other formats via google drive
an activity dashboard to monitor monitor
approval workflows
default text formatting and more fonts
spelling and grammar improvements
add-ons and many security features
including limited access rights
exploration and exporting
that's a lot of information to take in
if you want to learn more about google
docs
or review some of the things we've
discussed here learn more today by
visiting the g suite learning center
at the link shown on your screen okay
stay tuned for live q a
we'll be back in less than a minute
hi welcome back we've gotten a number of
questions from the audience
and now we will answer them so the first
question says that doesn't keep people
from making copies of a document though
right this refers to the security
feature where we
disable copying what that does is the
sub disables the
uh file copy entry in the menu
and therefore people cannot make copies
through that mechanism
second question can i share a document i
make in google docs
with someone without a g suite account
absolutely
when you send out a document by link
people who click on the link will be
able to see your document
a cheesy account is not necessary third
question
when i share the document can the other
person know all the previous versions
and comments this depends on how you
share the document if you share it in
view only mode the person will not see
comments
or previous versions if you share it in
edit mode then they will be able to see
those things
next how do i limit access to a document
so only people at my company
see it by default when you create a
document
you choose who can see it so
if you choose to let people outside of
the company see it then you're giving
them
explicit permission but but documents by
default are only limited to the people
you have
expressly given access to
finally can i link to a specific part of
a document absolutely one of the
features in google is the bookmark
and you can insert a bookmark at any
point in the document and then you can
link directly to that point in the
document itself
i believe that's all the questions we
have
so that's all for today please tune in
next tuesday
for the next google cloud on-air webinar
and thank you for watching
you